check this out so we were shouting out
Tom McDonald you guys know Tom right yep
he's number three billboard digital
sales with his new song Riot I looked on
the other charts I couldn't find them
maybe I just don't know where the charts
are but I looked hip-hop and rap and
he's not there and I'm like something is
BS there's no way dude got millions of
hits when he dropped that music video
and he's number three in digital sales
I don't trust the industry at all no
they'll do whatever it takes except cult
and they want to control the yards to
control the narrative and manipulate
people but more importantly they want to
make sure you guys stay in line they
want you so we were talking about the
show uh earlier in the show about a
particular band I don't want to say the
band I don't like Dragon other people's
rights and things but a big band and all
of a sudden they're like posting things
about abortion and stuff like that and
I'm like I think they're woke and then
you guys were saying nah they probably
have managers who told them they have to
post it yeah because you get you get
blacklisted like if you don't comply you
start noticing your opportunities going
down right but what Trevor was saying it
doesn't matter when you have amazing
fans when you have amazing fans they
lose their power the media the media was
more powerful I think they're becoming
less trustworthy overall and and over
the past couple years because people are
kind of like being a they're aware more
now than ever of what we're being fed
constantly is not the truth so so I
think the media is losing its luster a
little bit and I think that the music
industry is just another Avenue that the
media media uses to to brainwash people
or control people or that's a whole
other can of worms but they're using
their biggest artists to try to yeah
it's like a battle of the Cults you know
I mean no matter what we're all in Cults
if some sort of way beat your family
maybe it's your friend group maybe
that's Community
okay
for yourself don't don't look at me but
hold on to go back to the the topic that
we were just discussing here to segue
this conversation music and performers
were always kind of known as being
anti-war what do you guys think happened
to this anti-war element the first thing
that comes to mind is this famous saying
by Tupac they got money for Wars but
can't feed the poor we don't see that
those kind of lyrics we don't see this
kind of galvanizing anti-war push
anti-establishment push from the music
industry like we used to what happened
what do you got these artists are
selling their soul it's not it's not
pure
passion anymore it's more just about the
money The Bling whatever whatever their
shortcomings are like whatever the the
the there they want you know in the in
the short term instead of thinking about
a long-term passion long-term goal so
whatever they got to do to to come up
that and like so quick
you know they're they're just gonna
follow whatever orders they got I think
what we're seeing right now is that
they're always there's always been a
contingent of people with no morals no
principles they just want they want
stuff they want money they want power
and they want social acceptance yeah and
what's happening is because the internet
you can you can see it's it's being
filtered out and so those people they're
they're they're the ones who are going
on Twitter and they're like you know in
big bands or whatever and they have the
Ukrainian flag and they're just saying
like yeah War sure whatever you say
because like I was just saying if you
guys you know go to a festival or you
get you get a manager or whatever and
you'll be like yeah tell them we want to
do a festival benefiting Ukraine oh then
all of a sudden they're gonna be like
we'd like to get the Rolling Stone there
we have to get New York Times there
they're going to do a profile on you
they're going to give you as big you
know multi-page spread in magazines or
websites I guess people don't buy
magazines anymore and then they're like
we're gonna sign a deal with you and
give you everything you want if you've
supported the war machine I think it's
also the lack of Education in the
schooling system for the younger
generation I think a lot of these people
don't even know what anti-war means and
I want to make a distinction here
because you could still support Ukraine
and still be anti-war there still is a
human cost to this war that's affecting
everyone that gets lost and you know the
humanity is being lost here because all
we're seeing is pro war Pro you know
bomb bomb said more weapons said more
murder except you know we should we
should be hearing we should be having
those conversations saying let's try to
stop the murder maybe and and and and
music used to be that vessel used to be
that voice that used to break through
the the news break through the
conditioning and inspire people to stand
up for peace and I think that got taken
out by radicals in a sense I do I think
the music industry has been overtaken by
by radical ideology from the top the
leaders of it because if if if you were
to make a song like that right now like
what you're saying you you would be you
would I think you could end up dead as
an artist I think you would I think
you'd if you wrote a song that that kind
of went that against the grain like you
know people are starving you know I
gotta I'll push back I think maybe a few
years ago but we're seeing people doing
it yeah they are now like a lot of I
mean well I mean Tom McDonald the
obvious one but um the Dixie Chicks
called out the bush invasion of the war
in Iraq didn't they walk that back and
then they dropped Dixie from their names
or whatever yeah or whatever and then
you had um the uh Lady Antebellum I
think they like changed their name to
Lady Abe but it turns out there's a
black blues singer named lady a and she
was like you're a racist for stealing my
name or something there's just no
there's no winning but but I'll tell you
right now there's a um who's another
other other rapper Who's done Bryson
gray is that his name yeah so there's a
bunch of people who are outright calling
at the machine and they're gaining in
popularity so I think I think you can
push back I think that the pushback has
happened but correct me if I'm wrong I'm
a big fan of Tom McDonald but does he
play live I don't know I don't think so
I don't think and a lot of these artists
that are speaking out don't play live
and I wonder what the I see what you're
saying what the repercussion would be if
they were to play Live you know like you
need security you need yeah you know oh
yeah yeah we put on an event a few years
ago and antifa some antifa guys called
up and threatened to burn the theater
down and so they waited to the very last
minute and the theater cancels on us so
we ended up moving the event to a casino
so the event still happens but it cut
our capacity down we did our after party
in the same place they show up they were
threatening us outright the cops like
we're not gonna do anything about it it
looks like Tom played live until October
2020 since October 23rd at JJ's Bohemian
Chattanooga Tennessee was his last show
according to
bandsantown.com I don't know or he's
just not listing them anymore I mean I'm
sure they love live performance but I
know what you mean it can get a bit
chaotic we got to get rid of these the
we we we're not getting rid of them but
we got it we gotta stop the cowards
because I know for a fact we went to
Blue Ridge Rock Fest it's huge it was
amazing
and I'm walking around and people are
like yo hey what up Tim you know a big
fan and I'm like oh wow band members
other stuff there were like four bands
that were familiar with IRL that were
fans of the show and I was really cool I
was like how is it that so many people
here even the performers are fans of our
show
how are they not speaking out
challenging this stuff just telling
everyone to shut it down I don't think
it's it's you know at a place like that
where I suppose if everybody already
agrees and they're like get that woke
crap out of here you know I understand
if they're not making it their entire
lives I don't necessarily want to go to
a rock show and be lectured to or
anything like that but I'm like how is
it that the industry still has to
Stranglehold when so many of the people
there reject the ideology but I guess
the end of the day they just say yes to
their managers or whatever the leaders
so that's where that's where it all
comes down to it's it's also the the
whatever whoever's leading the band too
if you have the the leader of the band
The the star of the show and you you
know someone who's a member is saying
they love you
quietly
the leader of the ACT might not think
like that also they might be programmed
by because they're usually they're the
ones dealing with the managers the
labels the it goes beyond that it really
it really is a deep entrenchment and and
if you want to continue to have almost
this meteoric rise or these
opportunities continue to come your way
you you have to comply if you stop
complying you find yourself
having to be independent or go on your
own or have to build a house out in the
middle of nowhere and be
self-sustainable right you're you're
exiled from the community uh in a sense
so I think to answer your question
the guitar player of a band may be like
I love you Tim
but he's not gonna go out and and say
that or do
what he feels because he could be kicked
out of the band by the the person that's
look at look at Pete Parada right so he
we worked on a song you got to work on
working on a bunch of more songs with
him he's a former drummer of The
Offspring he goes to his doctor and
doctor is like yeah you can't get the
vaccine because you have you have a high
risk for gambarra and he's like oh man
that sucks so the offspring's like
you're fired right he's like bro like
you don't even disagree with him and the
crazy thing is he didn't disagree with
them just like my doctor says I can't
get it and they're like oh well dude
you're fired and then all the media
writes is an anti-vaxxer yeah these
people are an occult man so I can
understand why people are scared for
sure but that's why I was like for one
it was it was awesome to work with Pete
because it's like I've been listening to
offering since I was a kid so it was an
honor to be able to have such a good
drummer plus he was in face to face and
he toured with a bunch of other bands
and uh but it was it was it was a huge
Market opportunity I'm like we get this
great drummer they're losing out but the
other thing is we want to make sure that
if someone does speak out and Pete
didn't really even do that but if they
are going to try and come after you that
we're going to be building an industry
of in some capacity that's going to be
like now you're not going to be left
destitute we're going to we're going to
work on right there has to be a Ying to
the yang right it can't just be you're
exiled you're out here and now you're
getting rained on in the mud there has
to be another group of people that
welcomes you and supports you and and I
do agree with you I think that that's
growing and I think there's a community
of people that that are putting their
foot down because we we have to at this
point I think we're getting into it a
bit and I don't want to use the word
desperate times because I don't want any
fear Monger but I do think that we have
to start
speaking out about how we feel you know
us we have to start talking about we
can't be ashamed to say that we love
this country and we love Liberty and we
love freedom I don't know when that
became like like where you say that in a
room and no one likes you anymore right
like I don't there's a lot of things
that we're losing right now that that I
don't think is okay you know just like
country music you know what I mean I
mean it is look at you see John Rich put
out that song progress yeah and he's
just like sticker where the sun don't
shine and they're like yep and I'm like
well at least though that that whole
faction of people are are cool that
industry is is Trucking along it seems
like music industry in general has
always been about profit maybe not
always all but like since 1920 when it
didn't used to exist until radio like
they used to just play for food at night
and then that would be it that they
didn't were Rich at all and then they
started being able to control their own
well control their own couldn't really
control their own distribution that was
the labels came in and immediately we're
like we're gonna control your
distribution so when the then then that
died off in like 2001 with Napster or
like 90 87 or something and then the
artist started to be able to control
their own distribution now yeah so it
said but that old that old network of
people still is trying to profit off of
it but so like now there's like an
artist distribution thing it's just
diasporic like there's they're all over
the place and there isn't like a unified
it's very cartelic though I just want to
explain when I use this word it's a very
extreme word cartel but I I talked a
little about it earlier when we in
trouble were talking like the people in
the music industry will ruin someone's
life and lose no sleep over it and it
takes a certain type of person to do
that right they will they will shoot
someone in the head watch them drop dead
on the floor turn to their assistant and
say what's for lunch and not think twice
about what they've just done they will
they will take an artist who's a 20 year
old kid with dreams they will ruin his
career because of whatever reason they
want to and they will not think about it
again when they leave the room like for
people like us if if you hurt someone's
feelings or I love people I'm a people
person if I do something wrong to
someone
uh it bugs me right the the people
leading the music industry it doesn't
bug them they could literally ruin
someone's life and then never ever ever
think about it again yeah so they think
of artists as cattle basically yeah I
think it's more than I I think it's
beyond just money because there are very
talented very good people who don't get
any play on the radios or in the music
industry individuals like Lupe Fiasco he
was blowing up he was a major uh music
performer everyone loved him I
interviewed him along with Immortal
Technique at Occupy Wall Street and then
he went to Obama's uh unofficial
inauguration event and and while
everyone's there to celebrate Obama he
criticizes him in his drone policies and
and makes a song that literally has him
kicked out of the event and now of
course after that he doesn't get that
much play so individuals like Lupe
Fiasco Immortal Technique are
individuals that I listened to that
inspired me that are in the kind of
hip-hop cultural world but even rock
stars they're known as being
anti-establishment now they're like
super establishment remember when there
used to be this this really great band
they don't exist anymore I was a big fan
it was called what was it called rage
rage against the machine and now and now
it's like these days you know they're
not around there's a band that's just
called rage on behalf of the machine
correct so is it like because it used to
be Creedence Clearwater Revival talking
about you know Vietnam screw Vietnam get
the troops out War sucks and then when
Napster came out is it like there was a
moment where there was no music industry
for a minute and now they're like we're
just gonna get 14 year olds put them on
insane contracts and make them famous
they'll do whatever we say we'll just
pick people that want to be famous I
think I think John Lennon terrified him
you know because he's he's a this major
celebrity who's been like no to war and
they're like oh this is turning
sentiment against us and then all these
other bands follow look what happened
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there